السعاده والاكتئاب هل يمكن ان تجمع علاقه
بين هذين الشعرين في اوروبا منظمه التعاون
الاقتصادي والتنميه تكشف ان الدول
الاوروبيه الاكثر سعاده هي الاكثر
استهلاكا للمضادات الاكتئاب بالفعلوا على
غير المتوقع ارقام المنظمه اوضحت ان
متوسطه استهلاك مضادات الاكتئاب في 18
دوله اوروبيه ارتفع بمقدار مرتين ونصف من
عام 2020 حتى 20 20 الاغرب في هذه الدراسه
انا اكثر الدول استهلاكا كانت ايسلندا رغم
ان الدوله مصنفه من الدول السعيده بسبب
الطقس شديد البروده ربما لكن ما التفسيرات
المحتمله الاخرى لهذا الارتفاع المتضاعف
بهذا الشكل واين نحن من هذه الارقام لكن
قبل الارقام حديث في الاكتئاب والسعاده مع
سهى جميل من الاردن
[موسيقى]
اينما ذهبتم تسمعون امرا واحده الجميع
مكتئب ولا شك ان زمن كورونا فاقم من ازمه
الاكتئاب على امتداد العالم لكن ربما ما
يجب ان نتحدث عنه اليوم هو كيف نشخص
الاكتئاب والاهم كيف نخرج منه
[موسيقى]
دراسه امريكيه جديده اظهرت ان مؤشرات
الاكتئاب كثيره وواضحه ولفهمها ومواجهتها
لابد من الاخذ بعين الاعتبار الخلفيه
الثقافيه للانسان فلا تتوقع ان يتحدث رجل
اردني عن معاناته مع الاكتئاب كشخص فرنسيه
او ان يقول صديقا اردني لصديقه المكتئاب
اذهب واحصل على العلاج لكنه سيقول له
باللهجه المحكيه الاردنيه انسى الموضوع
كلنا مكتئبين توكل على الله
[موسيقى]
وعلى كل حال هذه مؤشرات للاكتئاب لا
تهملوها خساره الوزن صعوبه النوم الاجهاد
التعب قله التركيز وقله الحركه وبعيدا عن
الدراسات لابد ان الاصدقاء الكثر من حولنا
والروابط العائليه القويه تبقى حلا لكل
المشاكل
[موسيقى]
هل هناك علاقه بين السعاده واستخدام
مضادات الاكتئاب الجواب هو لا حسب بيانات
منظمه التعامل الاقتصادي والتنميه
الاوروبيه
في العالم لعام 20 وفقا لتقرير السعاده
العالمي لديها اعلى معدل استهلاك لمضادات
الاكتئاب في اوروبا السويد التي احتلت
المرتبه السادسه في تقرير السعاده لديها
رابع على استخدام جرعات مضادات الاكتئاب
اليوميه جمهوريه التشيك سجلت اعلى زياده
في نسبه استهلاك ادويه الاكتئاب وصلت الى
577 بالمئه واقلبه كانت فرنسا بارتفاع 38%
فقط وبالرغم ذلك لان هذه النسبه مرتفعه
ايضا
[موسيقى]
من الرياض الى نفسي دكتور اسامه النعيمي
دكتور مع ارتفاع نسبه تعطيها هل يمكن
القول بالفعل ان العالم اليوم مدمن على
حبوب الاكتئاب
صباح الخير سهام صباح الخير نادين صباح
الخير على العربيه مشاهدين مستمعين
والصفحين وصباحك زي لون قميصك يا اي لون
يا ابن مسك لا طبعا الادمان شيء واخذ
الادويه النفسيه اخر العلاجات النفسيه
تقريبا كلها
صباحك ابيض
او اكثر طريقه بسيطه
اه اوكي ههه
معلش معلش يعني الادويه الاسود يلون
الحياه احيانا
لون جميل
الادويه النفسيه بغالبيتها العظمى ليست
ادويه ادمانيه هي ادويه علاجيه تعطى
لاسباب معينه لفتره معينه لمساعده
المراجع على التخلص من اعراض يعاني منها
وربما مساعدته في اتخاذ قرارات واجراءات
قد يكون بحاج الاهلي يغير حياته وهي ليست
ادمانيا هذا يختلف جدا عن شيء اسمه التعلق
العاطفي اللي بيحدث عند امهاتنا مثلا اللي
تقول انا اذا ما اشرب فنجان القهوه او
كاسه الشاي يجيني صداع برغم انه ما في
علاقه بين الصداع والقهوه لكن في نوع من
التعلق عند امي وامكم انه اذا ما شربت هذا
الشيء وهي طالعه على السوق راح يجيها صداع
فلذلك هي الادويه ليست ادمانيه اساءه
استخدامها شيء اخر مختلف بس انا بدي اعرف
كيف بدي اعرف اني انا وصلت لمرحله
الاكتئاب وليست مرحله نكد او شعور بفقدان
الشرف لا مبالاه مثلا
اسمحي لي اجاوبك مرتين الجواب الاول انه
في اليه في شروط يجب توفرها بضمنها حاله
الحزن وفقدان الاهتمام الطلبات الوزن
اضطرابات النوم الافكار السلبيه الانعزال
من المجتمع اساءه استخدام المواد كلها هذه
يجب ان تحدث على مدى اسبوعين ثلاث مرات
خلال ست شهور مش لانه اليوم نسيتي او
صدمتي سيارتك او نسيتي
اكثر من اسبوعين وتكرر
اممم اوكي
وهذا الفرق بينه وبين انه انت مثلا تفقدي
شيء مهم وتحسي انه انت حزينه لفتره معينه
ثم تطلعي من هذا الشيء لان انت عندك
مقاومه للضغوط الخارجيه
الاخر اللي الان بدينا ننتبه عليه بزياده
بسبب زياده الوعي خصوصا عند جيل الشباب
والمراهقين انه بدا التركيز مش بس على
المشاعر انما على الشغل ان هم بداوا
يشعروا انه هو صح الاكتئاب موجود لكن هم
نفسهم يفقدوا الاهتمام ويفقدوا الرغبه بان
يقوم باشياء كانت تشعرهم بالسعاده سابقا
مثل العمل مثل الرياضه مثل الحياه
الاجتماعيه مثل حتى بعض الاحيان الحياه
الزوجيه
في مصر لماذا برايك ارتفع بشكل كبير
استهلاك حبوب الاكتئاب عبر العالم ونرجع
لك دكتور
[موسيقى]
للاسف في ثقافه فعلا منتشره على الانترنت
وفي الصيدليات وفي غيره اقرب واحد جاي لك
بيقول لك انا مش عارف انام ادي له دواء في
ماده فعاله مضاده للاكتئاب لو بصيت لنسبه
ارتفاع الطلاق والنسب الانفصال والكلام ده
زائد الغله والكلام ده على ما اعتقد يعني
انت بتلجا لحاجه تهدي اعصابك احسن ما تلقى
للمخدرات ابواب الاكتئاب وكده بتبقى اكثر
بره في اوروبا
احنا اكثر اجتماعيين وكده فبتلاقي الكتاب
قليل الجو الاسري بره مش مش موجود بالدرجه
الكافيه في احتماليه زياده
صاحبك او قريبك او كده تخلي الكتاب
اللي احنا ماسكينه ده تخ والله العظيم
الموبايل دوت خلى كل واحد قفل على نفسه
بقى هو اللي صاحبه قفل على نفسه فاصبح في
عز عن العالم
بالتالي بيجي له اكتئاب
[موسيقى]
دكتور سمعنا للشارع سطر يعني اسباب عديده
من بينها التكنولوجيا لو نص تسطر دكتور لا
خبرتك الاسباب الحقيقيه لارتفاع معدلات
الاكتئاب في العالم خصوصا بين دول اصلا هي
مصنفه انها دوله الدول اكثر سعاده
طب الفتره انا كتبتها موضوع كان اسمه
رفاهيه الاكتئاب وهذا معناها انه في بعض
الشعوب لديها القدره والامكانيه ان تشعر
بالاكتئاب بينما بينما شعوب اخرى ما عندها
لا وقت ولا مزاج ولا حتى اي خبره انه يشعر
بالاكتئاب حتى وان كانوا يعانون من
الاكتئاب وهذا السبب الاول انه زياده
الوعي بوجود الاكتئاب خلى تشخيص الاكتئاب
اسهل فخلى معالجه الاكتئاب اسهل لانه
الادويه النفسيه صارت اكثر فعاليه وقل
اضرار بالاخرين الشيء الغريب انه تدريب
الاطباء العموم واطباء الاسره على تشخيص
الاكتئاب المبكر ساعد انه يوصف العلاج
مبكرا همم اما في 2017
ظهر سببا اخر انه احنا دائما ننظر الى
الاكتئاب على انه الاكتئاب بالنمطي اللي
يصيب الرجال اكتشفنا يا اخي في عندنا على
كوكب نساء كمان نصابه بالاكتئاب وهذا ما
كنا حاسبين سبحان الله
ههه مو ممكن اكيد بسبب الرجال دكتور بدي
اتكلم عن الاكتئاب نعم الى اي حد الناس
تقلل من شان المرح والسعاده في حياتنا على
صحتنا النفسيه لانه معظم
الامر التي تراكمت بسبب الاكتئاب حصلت
يبدو انه احنا اصبحنا جديين اكثر من
اللازم بدينا نقنن كميه السعاده نخاف حتى
انه نعلن سعادتنا للاخرين يبدو ان احنا
استع- استعرضنا عن سعادتنا اللي كنا نشترك
بها احنا وعوائلنا واصدقائنا والناس اللي
بحبهم ببعض اللقطات على مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي كدليل على سعادتنا فجعلتنا اكثر
ابتعادا عن بعض وصارت علامات السعاده
عندنا هي كميه اللايكات اللي نحصل بالوقت
اللي كانت هي كميه الضحكات والذكريات
الجميله وهذا اللي ادى بينا في الوقت
الحالي مثل ما قال احد ضيوفكم انه اصبحنا
منفصلين عن واقعنا بسبب التكنولوجيا اللي
احنا نتكلم عنها بوجودك معنا
دكتور اسامه النعيمي تنورنا دائما دكتور
شكرا لك